so we got we got country Wayne coming in
one of my faves yeah I've been following
suit for a long time but then you kind
of started around the same time okay and
I had about 30 tour dates on the books
this dude I think had 300. he he's it's
going to be a very interesting you know
what you're gonna need all your wits
about you before because he's a sharp
smart dude his work ethic mops you under
the floor you need some magic my dude
I'm telling you supercharged right now
Daddy get that brain right
you don't need coffee getting that flow
State get into a flow State you get
mental Clarity there's a difference
between being jittery and shaky and
having Clarity and being alert you don't
want to be jittery on podcasts on stage
you want to be clear free-flowing get
that brain look turbocharged my boy the
guy who invented magic mind had a heart
condition couldn't drink coffee anymore
spent years with real real scientists
developing this and it's it's I swear by
it it's one of the best products ever
tried get some magic might be
is really the fighter and the kid come
on baby
I mean country Wayne's in the house if
you don't know who he is you're living
under a rock well we we I read he sent
me some articles I want to educate Brian
I because I I don't know about you for
hot sake a little younger than he is
yeah but um Gray beard because I
remember because how long have you been
headlining comic
um since
2016. so it was you know it was probably
right when you were first starting it's
like 2017-16 I was at palm Palm Beach
Improv in Florida and I was doing The
Late Show you're doing the early show
and I was talking the manager and I was
like and the crowd was Rowdy like you
were lighting them up in the manager I
was like who's out there in the first
show because they were sold out man it's
country Wayne I was like country Wayne
it was like a white boy from the
country's like no you're way off and
then a white boy from the guy watched I
was like oh this dude's hilarious they
came in the back I remember you were
like yeah I'm the road non-stop it was
like something crazy yeah it was crazy
dates back there or something nuts it
was I was on the road man you showed me
the schedule was every weekend because I
was trying to catch up from not being
experienced I was like I got to overwork
to you know you're coming from the
internet I was like man I got to use
this time you're so smart though because
that's you see a lot of people that get
internet Fame then they have to get up
on stage and if you haven't put in the
work they last one year sir last one
you'll see them like they're big on
YouTube or they're big on Tick Tock or
Vine whatever and then they start
headlining and then a year goes by like
where'd they go because they don't they
don't put in the work you because the
audience you you got one year yeah and
those you can't go back it wasn't a good
show you can't go back uh you want to do
it you won't grow see some people still
got the audience but they they do this
every year yep and then and you can't
grow until you you got to you can't
cheat to work because you could not
cheat it there's no way nobody ever did
it and you're not gonna feel good the
fruits if you don't work so yeah and
then think about that you go from
obviously the social media Fame you
decide to become a headline in comic you
put in all the work you're doing more
dates on everybody and then and down the
road what seven years later eight years
later now you got a Netflix special and
you it's just not one of those ones
where you have to advertise it yourself
like me my girl watching last night bam
you're on the front cover dude yeah man
it's wow and it's crazy my um my his
wife sent me this morning a text message
said uh 2017 I posted which where should
I shoot my the same day that the special
drop oh dope uh on the same date what
should I do my stand-up special at it
was like so it was like to me it was
divine man to be you know to have that
Netflix special I always had faith I was
gonna get one but you know it was God's
timing but yeah man it's um it's surreal
right now for sure well it's gonna it's
gonna
boost your ticket sales like something
crazy yeah you know that's how you get
stratospheric after a while that's what
that's what I'm hoping you came from
like that that story about the story is
wild coming from what seems like
impossible odds where the only way I
remember like Louis Armstrong great you
know he said where he came from in New
Orleans you either were a gangster a
pimp or a preacher and that was it for
you and if you were a gangster you knew
what was going to happen you were going
to be dead or in jail it was just a
matter of time and it just like the
story about you know I think it was your
uncle who turned you into basically he's
like here this is the only Avenue which
is yes
selling drugs like you know it was the
man that was the only thing in that in
that country time you either do that or
you go to a factory and work and I had
already had some kids so that factory
rejected it wasn't there enough was it
covering
work ethics still has to be there they
got to be there he can't get half your
own Supply it could be a lazy drug
dealer yeah money you know what I'm
saying I was good and Dodge bullets yeah
you were good though yeah I was I was
good at it uh I was very I was a good
salesman you ever think let me ask you
this do you ever wonder like how much
what do you think the percentages on
because I always feel like people like
you would have been successful no matter
what I mean you regardless you would
have figured out a way how much of that
do you think is what you were born with
and how much of it was being under
pressure cooker of your of your I mean
it's a hard question but I I think to be
honest that pressure helped because all
my I knew a lot of people who gifted but
that pressure is either gonna make you
or break you that's the truth it's like
scratching off a lotto ticket lottery
ticket and putting it under the machine
you really don't have to scratch that
ticket you could scratch the barcode and
see so I just think that that pressure
just pushed that puts that that
incompetitive edge I think you got to
have people say oh I'm not being
competitive you must be competitive at
least with yourself yeah you got to be
competitive of course you do especially
when you got little ones relying on you
yeah okay and little ones ten ten that's
impressive and plus they're mothers and
plus their cousins and plus hey it don't
never stop a squad yeah the ten I wish
that was it money you can manage my kids
because just moving out just stay with
me yeah everybody else disappeared oh my
God
the money would be ridiculous not the
kids it's what come with the kids so
true yeah but now like even on uh like
my dad like on YouTube or Instagram if
you're doing well on there like that
just reach a million views he's like
whatever but if you when I was on
Showtime or Comedy Central then all your
family and friends like oh you're rich
now so for you having this massive fall
on social media now they see on Netflix
like oh he's Tyler Perry Santa Claus
where's our money Santa Claus they
FaceTime me man
oh congratulations my sister in the
background we're rich I'm like oh my
goodness you don't know I'm not getting
paid it's not YouTube I'm not getting
paid off the views on this exactly right
and then it hopefully it goes this is a
big commercial that's all this is don't
they say NFL players the first thing
they tell you is with the NFL they'll
have a meeting back you you will go
broke not because of the cars you buy or
the house you buy it's friends and
family they're really family yeah family
boys hard to say no it's all it's hard
to say no you got to put it in the work
you got to put them to work so I just
put everybody in the skates man is that
right my content I make everybody work
18.
the oldest and the youngest is one
across the board it was like one but it
jumped it's a big jump we go one six
nine
twelve somebody's gonna be working 14
14.
uh 16
17 18. 16 16 18. now here's what we're
gonna do we're gonna tie you up a little
bit we're gonna tie your tubes up oh my
God we're gonna have to get that because
that's a lot now it'd be good to move
them into a big compound I got I got
they all stay in my house okay I mean
well they all got a room in their mom's
houses are right around my house but I
use their houses and Studios because I
shoot my content at their houses too and
it's a write-off yeah so so their houses
if I pay if I pay your bills I'm coming
I don't care if your boyfriend excuse me
sir but you got work to do also you want
to be in the skit yeah you want to be in
this kid everybody could be in a skit
man because like if you want them to
have a boyfriend you want them to have a
rich boyfriend you want them to have a
husband I'm praying right I'm praying
for it you just want them just like
marry somebody rich but they're good
I'll pay for the wedding they can't find
them I don't know what it is it was in
the rich man out there who got good
heart man I play them baby moms
but it also with what this shouldn't do
is like
Netflix is a big deal and it's going to
open you to a new audience but you're
fine even if Netflix didn't come along
that's what's dope that's why building
your own thing owning all your own [__]
is the move because you don't need that
cosign from Netflix or HBO show time com
Central if they come all good but your
audience still there because you build
it organically yeah it's I've been
growing and that's why I can't feel it
everybody's been asking how I feel
having a Netflix special I really can't
feel it it's like it's like well you
know you gaining weight you don't really
know to one day you look in the mirror
like wait a minute
love handles I gotta switch these
mirrors getting old but I've been
because nothing ever happened in my
career yet it was like a big boom
everything been there casual I've been
working even before comedy so I I always
been working working so I can't feel
I can't really feel the Netflix I just
know I'm acting out like yeah it's
Netflix but I can't really feel it
because I'm like man I'm grounding every
day I'm dropping 10 skits I'm every day
I think that's how it goes yeah I really
do I think we always talk about that
like you'll hit certain milestones and
then the problem is we're too busy
tomorrow you know what I mean you're too
busy that day to kind of stop and how
long have we been talking about having a
celebratory dinner in general never
happens yeah we don't do it you know
what I mean like you just get busy but I
I mean you might see a increase maybe in
your views on your skits or really you
don't see the impact on social media
like in in the space you're in to me
you'll find a difference from like your
peers you know you might get attacked
from somebody yeah like oh damn that's
what it did that's when you know it's
when when you're when like the guys you
look up to reach out like oh damn that's
how I know I'm doing something right
yeah Kevin Hart told me that uh before
the special but he didn't even know I
had a special coming but he was like um
I'm a fan of you and your business I
can't say I'm a fan of your company yet
because I haven't seen your stand-up yup
yeah I was like wow man I can't wait to
text you when it's awesome so we'll see
what's up see it now
I've been secretly working on that stand
up that was my gym because I knew the
sticker I knew I'm not stupid everybody
knew the internet comments we couldn't
do stand up so to have if I knew if I
could be the first one because it was me
even before me you know the big guys
were Logan Paul you know you know a
crossover so many of them failed though
yeah not not too many yeah they um most
of them fail as far as being legitimate
stand up I wanted to be the first one I
wanted to be the first one to make it to
Netflix doing stand-up that was my goal
and and that'd be that the peers and be
like I respect there is yep so I took I
took stand up serious man I study the
game I I had I watch I watch a comedian
and know why that worked about okay yep
that's why they do that and that's why
do that and that's why they do that
that's why they did big oh they got a
point of view you watch uh if you want
to see somebody who really crafts jokes
well Michelle wolf oh you won't shut up
oh my god I've been watching her the
last few days the way she crafts jokes
I'm like I mean I feel like and I don't
I don't want to say this but I feel like
if she wasn't a woman yep she probably
would have special probably would have
been 100 then how about episode you know
the other night redhead
she's so so good though the way she
crafts a joke the economy of words and
everything else
you got him
off in the room
redheads
she did hey everyone blew up I'm a
redhead besides Carrot Top that blew up
I don't trust him Michelle's more of an
Auburn oh my God
I don't trust them hey but shout out to
Michelle wolf man I was like is she
really spinning this like this every
joke it was crazy so you might be yeah
she might be the best I woke up I woke
up
you know she did the lighthouse
corresponding and lit him up oh I know
she's a Savage dude such a good writer I
think I think I think what it is
sometimes man I think sometimes uh with
people who real good on stage is that
delivery is still theater because
sometimes people I know people be too
selda sometimes you gotta
I lose weight on stage man oh yeah I
lose weight it's really a workout
because you got to use that diaphragm I
learned especially with black people you
got it they ain't playing you gotta go
to church with them I get a white
audience oh my God they'll let me take
my time this is going to be easy they
respect it yeah
tend to be more participatory yeah if I
may yeah they wanna they wanna they
wanna feel it and it's because that's
how church was it's our churches hey and
I went over there and it's like man so
when you're on that stage if you're
doing this
it doesn't go well it doesn't go well
yeah oh I do I never ate more dicks than
when I open up for Miss Pat in Miami and
I didn't know when Tom's girl hit me up
because he used to work with her I was
like bro cut the [__] come with the
fire I'm like I got it bro it did not go
well first five minutes I was like oh
I'm eating dick right now yeah and then
I finally got it back and then Miss Pat
came out because you know when they were
cheering by the end then when I get off
stage Pat goes out there I didn't know
she's like y'all gonna cheer for that
white boy like that I was like whoa hey
what the [__] yeah she's she's a Savage
she's basically Joey Diaz of female
Comics yeah yeah she reals man it's a
medium between those audiences I went to
Edmonton Canada Canada and all that and
uh I I had I learned yeah you know but
that's a very different culture yeah
it's a different culture so I learned
how to bounce between those audiences
because I'm like you know I grew up in
those towns too I grew up in those
country towns so I I knew how to
politique and then when you were first
getting to stand up who were you like
trying to Aspire get influence from like
who were your guys
um
I like the Cedric the Entertainer that's
why on stage or no I'm just saying in
general like that whole comedy the
social media YouTube influencer I just
see it I was all of them I just knew
they were winning yeah so I was I was
doing music at the time I quit because I
did something different online I just
did the skits I did I did act out on
those skits so I was I think I was just
inspired by the game man just from a
Living Color the the the Saturday Night
Live the Dave Chappelle when I seen with
this what people were doing online I
just seen numbers yeah I didn't see what
they were doing to try to I'm like oh
I'm Gonna Do Your Own Thing I'm gonna do
what I think you got business yeah what
I do what I think was I was acting out
those situations because there's some
Salvage like little Duvall's a monster
and he he you know his stand-up's great
and then he does the music then he got
king king's one King's my boy King's
great yeah King worked his ass off too
yeah similar to you with the stand up
where again I don't know anybody does as
much work into the stand up and it also
comes from that social media that you do
and that's been for a hot second yeah
grace period you have to do it in that
grace period because your fans give you
that first time they know you're not
that good
so what most comedians did on Internet
they got big ignored the stage then you
try to come back and now they're
expecting you to be at that level and
they're never going to let you grow so
it's like it's a timing thing it's like
driving a car you got to match the
clutch and shift the gear at the right
time when you pop you must go aim and
stand up because we all want to dodge it
yeah I even wanted to dodge it I'm like
oh I'm dodging stand up I'm going to
stay in Hollywood stand-up will be the
one thing that will always be there
exactly because you know with social
media like these like putting out videos
the minute you stop the minute you stop
you aren't in that algorithm like that
that go around and all of a sudden
That's it man I'll see you later that's
why I had to play I had to pay other
people to post like I post 10 videos a
day but damn only two or three of those
are me I pay I gotta I pay people to
keep it going to keep my page it's a
full-time job yeah this this day and age
like it's a full-time gig but stand up
will always be once you start developing
that audience and they get loyal to you
and you're and you were able to
communicate for an hour on stage and you
can sell twenty five hundred five
thousand tickets
now you're set you see it you say it man
well depending you never said you have
10 more kids we'll see yeah I need both
of them right now because boy I need
both of them of course let's take a
little break can we take a break dude
because I'll tell you I'm taking a break
in Spokane Washington you're at Genesee
Theater on Sunday in Waukegan Illinois
I've never heard of that and that's fine
Sunday to September I don't know my I
don't know Maps if you want to come sit
in a theater and watch me crush it for
an hour on a Sunday
Lord's day then come out so it is seven
o'clock forget something on a football
baby go see Brian Callan oh and we are
competing against Saturday Night
Football so anyway not a big deal
football or sitting with your family on
Sunday you come out to the Genesee
Theater and I'll be in Spokane
Washington one of my favorites I'll be
staying Coeur d'Alene Hall at your boys
spoken Washington September 21st 23rd
bring your dope ass truck so I can drool
over them that's Spokane watching this
freaking weekend skank Fest is next
weekend then I'm in Iowa in October
Niagara Falls is selling great Niagara
Falls Casino in New York there Chicago
December get your tickets at
thickboy.com Spokane you're up baby dude
I'll tell you what man
I was having my coffee this morning with
my magic mine put A little milk in there
dude no you know I drink it black and I
thought to myself
I was staring at these knots these
macadamia nuts I went what would it take
for me to develop a team to squeeze the
milk out of them nuts and pour it in
this coffee well you know what I thought
I got some good news 100 Mil I've got
great news for you House of macadamia
they're draining them nuts Macadamia
milk they're draining them nuts listen
bro they got Pure macadamia nuts that
they turn into a liquid somehow I don't
know how they do it but if you want your
if you want your coffee to have that
buttery Macadamia sort of texture to it
you know how you like because you
sometimes you drink it's smooth you're
like man this tastes like water with
just Dark Water sure why don't we look
it up why don't we soften it up smooth
it up silk it you know what it is you
know what silky let's get our coffee
silky silky nut in my coffee How about
if House of macadamia was giving you a
free gallon of macadamia milk when you
visit house gallon's Gonna Last me seven
years
I'll probably look at that again we
gotta you gotta free a gallon milk when
you visit House of macadamias.com
tfak a gallon of macadamia nuts the milk
to your cart with any products and use
code to get the chocolate covered
macadamia nuts get their freaking 45
um macadamia nut bars and then you get a
gallon of macadamia nut all you got to
do is go to House of macadamias.com
tfak to get that gallon gallon it'll
come as a case you just add the water
and you're good houseofacademias.com
tfak but that also keeps you hungry yeah
it keeps me hungry man I love I love the
um coming up with new material that was
a challenge when you throw away that
special I mean the hour now you got to
go out and come up with those jokes
we were doing the show and Bill did
something I thought it was really funny
but you know he was doing his thing he's
trying to figure it out and he had just
shot a special and I said that was good
and he goes I hate this I hate this
period at the time yeah I go I know he
goes I'm just like because you always
think can I write can I ever am I going
to repeat repeat myself can I come up
with new stuff is this ever going to be
the case and I've never not felt that
way after a special oh so you always
feel like you go I went through six
months of writer's block just recently I
was like I'm finished I'm done it's done
you ever see a bit you're like I don't
know how the hell that came up oh bro I
don't know how the hell did that that's
now how did I do now after a year of
just going like this you're like how the
hell I'm a nightmare too I'm sitting
there [__] I can't I suck I get my
life for [__] you know I'm in that
period now that's why I can't feel the
special because I'm like I got to go
beat that guy that's right you can't
enjoy it because I can't enjoy it
because like oh they sit in the
suggestion for the tour I'm like okay
what I'm gonna say I will though you
will
club now I got 40 minutes of new but 20
of that was already stuff I just didn't
use on special I got about 25 yeah a
brand new jokes within it took me um I
started in August back on the road and
coming close to me about a month and a
half I got like 25 and new stuff when
you when you were first starting out
with stand up did you ever have any uh
set you remember were you just ate [__]
yeah in the back you're like damn oh man
I just um I hosted it first
so I hosted it at first I didn't ever
take that risk smart I never took I
never took a risk on that stage I always
had something else going on so I ain't
never run towards the money so I just
played it and I always was a mental
learner yeah I could learn mentally and
like all my jokes I work out in my head
once I work on my head I don't have to
test it on stage I I sit there and I
think and I can talk about the two
people around me and they don't know I'm
trying to bit but no I I I I only think
I knew I respected it before I came in
so everything I went through and stand
up I already knew that yeah I respected
the game so much I'm like that's not
easy yep I don't even want to do it yup
but scary how did you teach yourself
like
um
this sort of work ethic and and about
life talk about that because you yeah
where'd you get that because you know
like you you were talking about how I
think you were in a car and your sister
said something like or somebody said
something like you're stuck mm-hmm and
they were like stuck as my baby mama
mama yeah and she said you're stuck so
if I if somebody's files for child
support you're going to be in that
factory the rest of your life and you're
never gonna break even so what what did
you do to get out of these impossible
odds it's their freedom man I I know how
Freedom feel like I had a lot of freedom
when I was young my mom transitioned at
a young age so I would work my butt off
like Jacob in the Bible to be free so to
have that freedom where I don't have to
do this if I don't want to I can't stand
when I'm in a position when I have to do
something like if I'm in a Hollywood
meeting and I'm like well it feels good
that I don't have to have the they're
coming here so so I'm gonna work my butt
I'd rather go through the pain and
discipline of the of the pre of the of
the pre-production of my life to have
the anxiety every day so it said Freedom
once I experienced it when I was young I
got addicted to that feeling so
when she told me I was trapped because I
thought we were cool yeah but that mean
in the back of her mind the whole time
you were cool as long as you're paying
bills yeah so now oh so you think you
got me trapped so I put I said okay so
they'll do that uh agent will do that a
lawyer do that a manager do that a
relationship I never want to be trapped
I want this situation relationship
business relationship
um intimate relationship I want
everything in my life to be mutual and
not travel so we could all bring
something to the table you see this with
kids who have Rich dads yeah same thing
you're always somebody's [__] or you're
always going to be in someone's under
someone's umbrella yeah branches yeah if
you don't have Independence but what
were the books you were talking about 48
Laws of Seduction you were talking about
yeah you know Rich Dad Poor Dad I read
all those books yeah 48 Laws of Power
yeah reach that poor dad uh become a
millionaire God's way what is that one I
don't know I forgot the guy who wrote
that one that was like the one he was
like it was it was so many quotes in
there that was sole profound in my life
he said if you do what others won't do
for five years you could do what they
can't do for the rest of your life then
I started putting math together I was
like okay the real degrees in college
you get a degree after five but if you
do something for 10 years that's why
college to be a lawyer a real lawyer you
got to do them 10. yep and it's like
okay if those systems been in place for
so long College I already know that to
so you apply to life in those books Rich
Dad Poor Dad and see Thomas Anderson all
right so seduction yeah become a
millionaire God's way that was the book
that really meant you just started
reading you just started what did you do
did you did you have these books
recommended or did you yeah I recommend
my dad was in prison my dad was in
prison and every time he went to prison
he was in his right mind because when he
was on the streets he always did drugs
like he wasn't a drug addict that you
could know because he always had money
to cover it but he was like you know he
did his thing and he didn't get a lot of
rest but every time he went to prison he
read he he he read and he was he would
tell me to go pick these books up so I
was like that's so interesting 20 20 20
1 22 20 reading these books and um and I
was I was at work when I read that book
I was working at a power plant I was
working at a um uh a power company you
know it's like I had quit the streets
because I want to be legit like I don't
want to sell drugs yeah but um but our
that book there man was it's he's
talking how to leave stuff in the past
when something has happened it's
happened don't dwell on the past has
your dad uh is he still with us oh yeah
yeah he worked he worked with me now oh
he does yeah man God how proud is your
dad he's proud man because we we sold
drugs together yeah
we used to always you know and we he's a
grandfather Yeah like he's hey man he he
he drive the Sprint on tour he handled
the house when I'm gone he uh when I got
to go he'll stay with my son take Marco
my son take my state of the house he's
real and I put him in the video so he
just on salary is that a weird dynamic
though because your dad works like I
can't imagine working with my dad oh it
would be tough now because even in the
streets my dad was the first one to give
up my uncle didn't want to give up that
I was on a different frequency but my
dad was like
Wayne kind of know I was always business
I understood business uh at a young age
so my dad kind of we've been even in the
streets I was a leader
um
56 that's my age yeah
and I'm 35 but
me and him um yeah we close though
that's dope man something about 56 to
you give up the fight too like you're
not really interested in competing
oh my dad begs the day yeah yeah for me
it's like I just want I want results and
I wanna I wanna make sure I want the
best way so if I've got a you know I I
don't know it just would be but but I
agree that it's when you're working with
your dad it says a lot about him the
family yeah that he can and it says a
lot about you too you guys oh I love my
dad because a lot of my brother sister
judged him because he wasn't there all
the time and all that but man I've been
I'd never blame my parents for nothing
that everything that went on in my life
yeah because the only thing your parents
you know is if you think your parent bed
is always a word okay yeah my my daddy
had me in a bad environment it wasn't
there all the time but he was the one
that told me don't have all these kids
yeah he did take my hips
take it to those rooms and do this right
here without a car so yeah so everybody
I think sometime when kids go through
things they want to blame the parents
I'm like come on let's be real yeah well
what does blame do anyway like what like
you could sit and you you may have a
very like I always say you people have
very good excuses for not moving ahead
they're a good excuses it doesn't matter
though it doesn't matter man like yes
yes everything bad went on now now you
can talk about that and worry about that
or like you said from that book that's
your past that's the past you can blame
people and you will turn your back on
your future that's what I said now do
these 10 kids do they want to get in the
business like in Show Business I know
they work with some work with you but do
they want to be actually in the business
they all they all do
and um like they all do but they just
um some of them being ambitious about
like Melissa's and dance and she's he
works hard but they're you know they're
rich kids they work it's different they
don't have that pressure they'll yeah
and I tell them all the time I say man
y'all have a kid and I'm staying and I
stay on them I say bro when you because
it's the blessing the curse like what
you just said when you a rich kid now
you got that pressure cause they
watching you yup differently you got to
work even harder than me but they just
don't they don't have the it's tough
like because you know we're all doing
well in here and we we all have kids so
it's like you you want to give your kid
the best life we don't give them too
much with these little [__] yeah you
know just expect all this stuff yeah
because then they don't get a work ethic
it's tough man it's a fine line I stay
on them though um I just keep it real
with them I got my son Tamar and they
and one thing about my kids they really
listen because I'm real real with them
their mom would be like good game nah
man
you stop talking about the NBA Union
oh I'm the exact same do you you see
your left hand exact same my son was
playing a football that's what a
father's job is though yeah you got to
represent the real world it made him a
closer now that's rare though it's rare
though so especially out here like my
son's playing football and they were
terrible and I was like where's the
score what's the score like we're gonna
keep scoring like the [__] we don't rest
the game I bring a scoreboard 14 nothing
like if you think it hurts a kid's
feelings I'm like where I come from
these little [__] need to know
they're not good yeah so we're not
keeping score they they think
everything's all good if you were you
were a professional athlete yeah you
know oh no [__] it's 28 to zero
it is 28-0 y'all it's halftime what are
we gonna do different those orange
slices the prime nobody's getting that
I believe in that though right yeah hell
yeah
hell yes
it's coach Brendan half y'all shouldn't
be on the field but we're entertaining
him he would check friends of mine my
friends would be like my friend
he played T1 football went to the
Buffalo Bills for a couple minutes and
but he fought in UFC you know so he's
pro athlete and uh and he said uh my
friend said you played in high school my
friend said I'm just talking to you guys
my friend goes I ran a 4-5 in high
school and Brandon didn't even look
Brandon didn't even know him he goes no
you didn't
and I told him I said I don't think
you're lying I think your coach who did
the time
I've seen a four or five you don't run a
four or five you don't run a four or
five you know again I'm sure you've
carried that story for how long how long
he's like four I'm like 40. we all do
yeah I don't think you're lying but I
think your coach with the handheld timer
lied to you you're on a four nine and
that's then that's good I said you're a
short Jewish guy you're the first Jew to
run a four or five okay oh my God
my friend's jewishness sons was really
good at basketball and he literally
satis down there and he goes listen
you're very good at basketball you are
never going to be in the NBA you
understand that because you're Jewish
I'll tell my son that he's playing
basketball I used to have fun playing
with my friends like the NBA is not for
you you just you're like why I'm like do
you turn on the TV you have eyes bro
yeah you know do you see any Mexicans
out there on the floor
you see one Mexican bro none dude are
there any soccer baseball football
soccer baseball football
boxing yeah look at this don't worry if
you have to look and think there's not
one Mexican in the NBA
well I could be I could be the one no
yeah but if I see them working towards
you think about it I'm like you on the
varsity team and you're playing the game
all day you're showing me you don't want
it right so it's like you got to show
you gotta I'm actually gonna speak
louder than words I agree hey you racist
[__] Juan Toscano Anderson Eduardo
Nigeria look at that no no this is of
all time I'm just saying man I'm [__]
offended right now I want to apologize
to you country Wayne oh man all right
well I'm looking it says as of now there
are two Mexicans look at that dude wow
that might be my son Tommy Hawkins
junior he just got drafted by Miami okay
okay so you got one
okay you got one the guy before that the
guy before that looked like he was a
little black too
yeah okay also that's a very s that he
might be from Spain bro yeah maybe I
mean yeah it's crazy but y'all kind of
favorite I'm serious
like that guy right here y'all kind of
look alike right here seriously I mean I
got yeah most people thought I look like
in Hernandez
yeah he's got that look
same body types
come on
when he was on trial I was in Maria Del
Rey picking up like Twizzlers or
something I was in line to the grocery
this dude's on trial and I hear the guy
behind behind me going no I'm I'm
telling you he's right in front of me no
this [__] is right that's that's
him I don't want to go with that
statement go back to that go back to
that wait so go back that's crazy look
at this crazy come on man that's crazy
right come on
and they're the same size too same
height same body type what position you
play tight end you play you play tight
end and then Tim Tebow is my boy and I
did his charity golf tournament and
people like Aaron this dude's on trial
for murder I'm at this I'm drunk at a
golf tournament though Hernandez and
finally I was like no no in the final
like [__] it just start signing
autographs as Aaron Hernandez yep yep
what up yep there you go sun and knives
and [__] it's cool were you an athlete
you played some sports yeah yeah I
played basketball baseball football okay
I was pretty good too I was pretty good
yeah I'm competitive man yeah yeah I'm
competing yep that's a lot of it too
just not wanting to just not wanting to
be the guy on the bench in life yeah
like yeah exactly you know especially if
you like to talk if you're going to be a
talker and you gotta back it up you
gotta kind of
man if I lose it's gonna be because it
won't be because I didn't get my all
it's going to be hey man but I I I'm a
competitive because I like to have fun
it's fun being competitive I think you
get something also from the reach like
when you reach for something and you
reach for it in Earnest with everything
you got you're gonna land somewhere good
right so you might you might fall short
of this goal you thought was your goal
but it might lead you because it's I
think there's something about a reach
that's honest like there's some there's
truth to it right so if you're really
honest about what you want like really
honestly and then no but I'm saying then
you reach for it you're gonna you're too
serious but you're gonna end up they do
Serious Force right guys buy my book you
can do it hard talk you can do seriously
that was hey ain't gonna lie brother
that was profound see
man you explained in a book
you ever have this stuff oh no oh it's
like a it's like a nootropic it's like
it's like an energy shot like but it's
it gets you it's better than coffee
I'll put it here you didn't give us that
Hallmark response and then push this ah
I'm not pushing it I'll just give it I
don't want to drink something that we're
not that he's not allowed to drink it's
poison yeah
it has to be tough right now that you're
getting bigger because you've built it
all yourself and then Hollywood comes
and you realize just a different kind of
games different kind of games because
you have a you have an eight you have
representation now yeah I have agent
managers I've been had them since 2017.
I I went through a few managers but
marriage is a little different but when
you're with the big does like WME UTA
usca and uh I was I I moved out here for
two years three years studying the
business I wasn't even trying to really
get in nothing I was studying the
business and how they move out here in
L.A that's how I went home back to
Atlanta during the pandemic and built
what I did on social media because I
knew how they moved so I paid I paid
attention you did well in school
oh when I when I wanted to yeah when you
wanted to yeah but I think too with
agents it's kind of like they're not an
end-all be-all meaning you use them get
let them open up the doors by the end of
the day you can't just rely on them yeah
it's just coming from our background
that's the game you can't like use them
to open the door and give you the
opportunity and if you let me into the
room I'll I'll sell myself better than
anybody but I can't expect him to do
that you know what I'm saying so a lot
of agents are like what would you say
you do just make the introduction get
out the way yeah that's all I need you
for I'll take your 10 shut your mouth
yeah exactly I want to put my agent in a
position where they have to lie to me
yeah you want to keep them on as you got
to work man as an artist it's like man
this is the comedy business this is the
entertainment business if you just want
to be an Entertainer just want to be a
comedian you're going to get pimped in
the business that's just so you can't
get mad like it's like it's not good
people because people got bills people
got Yachts to buy yep and bills me
coming from lack of income situation it
it'll have you in survival mode so you
could be in survivor mode with a bunch
of money yep so if agents ain't reach
that top level yet well they can be good
or whatever man it's strictly business
you know anytime you think it's
passionate no and somebody cares that's
where you're about to follow this hole
man because this is what you're doing
this is the world this is not heaven
this is Earth and it's a [__] it
hurts it's shrooms in the air that's
about to kill us yeah so imagine humans
yep who causing you remember the movie
The Matrix hell yeah and uh it was
somebody somebody told me about this
part in the movie I didn't even really
see it I had to go back it was like you
uh you say we are the buyers yeah we're
we're the ones killing we're trying to
kill Earth Yep and Earth is fighting
back so if mainly Chinese but yeah yeah
hey hey
uh hey
hey I thought you said something oh God
this Brothers hold on that was it sorry
that was a that was that was it hey that
was a commercial break from our this
brother just let it out man we just made
his fun of me
ladies and gentlemen I want to apologize
once again everybody trying to kill
everybody how many times on y'all
situation you had to be like oh my God
bro bro you'll say something and I just
stop I just go like that and then every
now and then Brian go edit that out take
that out and it's funny because he
looked at you every time
he never said he looked I watched him he
say something that ain't two offenses
but it's real funny he looked that way
when something it was something that
might oh he like you his Checker he
looks pretty good
my neck gets hot I'll go like this just
get all quiet yeah man how long have you
been doing stand-up uh eight years now
hey what about you 47 years
30 years even though this man brother
I'm old yeah man I came up without all
the old guys from Rogan to yeah how long
how long was Rogan doing stand up Joe's
been doing it for real it's like over 30
years for 35 years he started when he
was young man Joe started when he was uh
I think he literally so what really what
really blew him out of the podcast no uh
news radio was like his first
introduction I was like a major team he
was always success Joe for 25 years the
biggest Was Fear Factor 30 years now huh
Fear Factor people get it twisted like
Fear Factor was a major Network TV major
and he's the face of it and then also at
the same time UFC started to pop so he's
a face UFC he's on Fear Factor so he
really see that right there that's 19.
that's me and Joe in 1990. so he he just
always been he always had it no no so so
so go to go to news radio he was the
face of UFC like so oh that was that was
but but so if he was with USC before
even Dana he came to La so that's that
was always been bottomed up though yeah
what year was that though look up when
news radio was because Joe was on a
sitcom before that so he came to LA in
1995. there you go 95. so I've known Joe
since 1996. no I've known Joe since 1995
because he guest starred on that TV yeah
so he was he was a guest star on Mad TV
and we had a sketch together we didn't
know each other and that's how we became
friends in 1995 ladies and gentlemen
that was before like movies had sound
that's [__] crazy and uh and that's
how long we've been together I know I'm
an old man you were probably better what
a wrong with y'all too man yeah we're
weird yeah a little weird man welcome to
fire the kids welcome to fighter but
when you talk about like work ethic like
yeah and people are like oh whatever
shop is a professional athlete's work
ethic it's like there's that and then
there's the Joe Rogan working oh there
we are like he outwards all of them yeah
they're fighting close man yeah that's
that's us that's that's embarrassing I
was in a speedo why you guys sound like
little kids because I have problems and
uh I was I played pool boy and that was
Dixie West wrecksworth and he was a
guest on there and uh it was a very
interesting thing man that's why
everybody who got those layers of
careers like did different things I
think they fans just
[Music]
I'll have people come up to me like uh
they'll be like oh uh Rogan does stand
up the guy from Fear Factor i'm like
[__] it is 2023. he sells 14 people
he's been doing yeah he does Arena he's
a read act he called me up he goes I was
in Salt Lake I was in Park City with my
parents he goes uh what are you doing I
go I'm in Park City he goes I'm in Salt
Lake come down I go what he goes you got
to see this uh 14 000 people I'm like I
I can't he goes get down here you got to
see it it said so I go down to I drive
to 45 minutes down Salt Lake and I'm in
traffic and I'm like the [__] is with
this traffic it was for my friend yeah
it was for my friend because 14 000
people descended on this Arena to see
Joe Rogan and and he was in the middle
of fourteen thousand people so the stage
was in the middle and I was like oh he
does yeah he does stand up he does some
stand-up but he's a guy who is always
successful because he nobody worked
harder and nobody was more consistent
like he's that one of those guys who can
focus so I remember one time he played
he was playing this game quake
I don't know [__] about video games but
this is back kind of when the internet
was just beginning when it would take
forever to download an image you know
and he had a whole room of computers and
I remember I went to Fry's and he went
and bought a circuit board so he knew
how to put a circuit board more I was
like the [__] is this guy you know and
he would play this game quick and it was
the first time you could play against
people in other countries and everywhere
so he became obsessed with Quake where
you're shooting each other I guess it's
like Call of warfare
yeah
I'm old so you know why I stopped you
know why I said a Halo Call of Duty
warfare here's why I stopped playing
video games here's why he gets he's so
intense
that he he was playing against some
people
he got up
to go get some water because he he
dawned on him that he was thirsty and he
fainted
and he realized he'd been playing for 15
hours without a break he'd been playing
for 15 hours that's how [__] nuts he
gets it's a bit of OCD competitive yeah
workout competitive as hell yeah and his
his thing too is he knows it's crazy you
know something about everything yeah I'm
just like we have the same truck I'm
doing this for him because you know what
he's doing right now he's literally gone
I got to play for 15 hours I wonder if I
I can see you doing that you're like
you're like
every time I try to be crazy my kids
break it but besides working kids what
do you like what do you do for what do
you spend your money on I'll see that
dope change Jesus is popping yeah about
things um but you know it's really it's
really my family man it's really my I
spend my money on going forward I throw
my money forward you're invest in
yourself I miss myself to keep that
money coming yep I try to build it uh
that that's passive income bigger yeah
like I learned that in the streets you
know sometimes I ain't buy much money
you guys how much money you got coming
so I try to I'm I want to get to the
point of
uh man I'm able to be free so I mean
with this mentality you're about to be
the next Tyler Perry yeah man you're not
okay yeah man I just I learned from them
guys though like my social media
business
I don't know why he's saying this like
when a bomb goes off and the delay hits
what did he say hilarious I missed that
part you like Tyler Perry but not gay
but not good hey you don't play a woman
that many times in a movie and just all
good you know what I'm saying hey he's
playing his mother dude yeah yeah
spreading rumors yeah yeah man is
married yeah yeah no gay guy gets
married ever I don't know oh I have no
idea I don't think so there he is I
don't know man no I don't think so he's
definitely gay oh my gosh
you know he has a compound in Atlanta
yeah he owns it like him and Coca-Cola
own Atlanta yeah yeah he owns Atlanta
when you're that rich you can be
everything you know what I mean yeah he
he got to say you're gay you know you
know what I mean like if you're a
billionaire oh my God you have sex with
a man it's like I'm just a billionaire
anybody with me no okay that's cool I
don't know if the internet looks at it
like that but
he's just in a weird [__] oh really okay
but this is y'all got the right name
listen you want to stick your finger in
the cage you're going to get bit
sometimes
yeah so where do you go from here are
you doing like a big media blitz what's
the oh yeah man you know we're doing a
media but man right now just focus on
getting them new jokes I'm sneaking in
these comedy clubs that's all you care
about yeah and and posting this um a
song about um is this it's his first
year of Varsity in 11th grade this year
what sport um basketball oh nothing
better
um yeah she got some height huh uh he's
his foot he dunking you know what I'm
saying but his damn my other son he
wouldn't play college really oh wow yeah
um last year 18 year old yeah he's all
it was his it was his first year of
Varsity last year because he taught us
ACL he got beat up at the Juco you know
Santiago but he was first team and all
day you know they're pretty good they're
pretty they're good enough I go to
Varsity games and everybody like
data ones yeah you know so they dunking
in
and shoot it's going some 38 points
sometimes sometime 15 you know and thank
God because those games are long like my
son's in baseball I feel bad for some of
the dads like when their son gets up I'm
like I can't imagine how he feels right
now like this my son's you know he's
good yeah the game's a little boring for
me if your son's the worst I wouldn't go
you still got this schedule I want to go
I'm not supporting you if the [__]
supporting you already yep exactly yeah
I'm not doing it yeah and I don't feel
bad like I might as well go to work if
he got to figure out what your future
gonna be because now you're wasting both
of our time yeah my daughter I mean my
daughter quit
she was tall I was like oh my gosh she's
gonna be good she taller and everything
I said boy I got mail she's gonna be
good
paying more about 40 Grand man the first
forty thousand dollars
but we'll pay her medical
ah [__] don't be amazing they do them
wrong man
but she didn't have it you made her quit
if you stick with it baby you make 50
grand for the LA spark yes you know it's
Oregon it is [__] up we're gonna work
at Starbucks why is it though cause
female tennis female UFC oh I'll tell
you Brian because nobody's watching but
I'm saying women a lot of advertisers
they watch it a lot of like women's
gymnastics women's track we all watch
that they make money do they oh they do
but women's track makes money yeah I
mean so that's it some of the top women
women's tennis does yeah you got women
in the UFC they do well yeah I mean
there are there are some sports right
yeah like in the Olympics you get like
the swimmers once every four years yeah
but there are other sports aren't there
like yeah it's tough bro they should
stop it at College I ain't gonna say to
stop it
wait truth truth just popped out truth
they should stop in college I didn't
mean it that way but he that's exactly
oh my God
y'all Spirit don't hit me
hey don't get on our Vibes yeah please I
think one of these I think they should
make like the uh the college teams yeah
be NBA teams or let the NBA like the LA
Laker Girls yeah and they should go play
right before the
like
like my Souls they canceled no no like
Varsity you know like Varsity games he's
like you know you don't have the mascots
come out at halftime just make them the
women no ultimate you know in high
school the girls play before the boys
yeah so I think if they just like the LA
Lakers got a team Atlanta Hawks have
they team but I feel like before anybody
gets in the state
they play at one and then the Lakers
play at seven people are gonna stick
around you know what I mean like a
warm-up thing like they'll just get the
court ready so before anybody gets here
I mean there'll be people
you get two games well they get to watch
the men for free is what I'm saying is
that too much it's all tough
some can hoop though that's where dudes
get it [__] up they get it twisted
like we could beat them like bro when I
was playing that CU we used to go to the
rec center and the whims team would be
there they used to hoop us up come on
all D1 athletes they're just
fundamentals pass the ball pass shooting
they don't miss yeah it's a new business
how long does it being baby around it's
probably just a new business for real
yeah it just takes a while to get wrong
the colleges college is still jumping I
mean a college female I prefer college
sports over Pro like I love college
football pro football I don't know I
love college too much money to be
competitive
they're just so good they don't make a
ton of mistakes and if the if the line's
like minus six it's sometimes there's a
game where it goes you know a different
way but in general they call it like you
know what to expect yeah College these
[__] would be up 40. for whatever
reason they get on Focus they lose 40 to
42. like I like that that amateur yeah
they [__] up
um
that's for sure
yeah the point is we're fans of female
basketball definitely yeah some of them
I want to invest in one do you
[Laughter]
what about women's soccer
they they got out of the what's in the
second round yeah but there seems to be
interest in that am I wrong or is that
just yeah they're being pushed by the
very liberal media though uh no they
they dominate for for for two of the
whatever you call they did well I don't
know bro okay you know they did well and
then they did bad this last season I
thought women soccer was jumping though
I think I think that that that's that's
where they excel in them women's tennis
and then the UFC like chefchenko oh yeah
Melissa Grasso uh that's it but then
there's some no the Cortez there's a lot
of badasses in the UFC yeah yeah yeah
yeah Alex Morgan is Big I'm trying here
um volleyball go back up most popular
women's sports go up Serena Williams is
big no up or down scroll up basketball
that's down gymnastics athletes hello
athletes ice hockey no swimming tennis
after basketball's a random article yeah
oh it's a real soccer yeah
yeah but what sports do you you watch uh
you watch all three Sports oh yeah oh
you know I'm a Cowboys fan okay you mean
Cowboys fan from Georgia oh man what's
up man you know you're not a Atlanta
Finn I'm not I'm Dallas Cowboys they're
good this year yes man yeah they're good
yeah they look good they've been good
for real for three years the outfit is
you know but the defense been there so I
just feel like this year the defense
know that was like the best defense and
they've stepped into that and the
offense just got they put against the
Jets they've looked I mean they beat the
brakes off the Giants they get the best
defense player in the league yeah we
scored 40 let's go 30. man uh Mika
Parsons Savage Savage him or what he's
had the broken man he's about to get
paid man hey he should what he's been
playing I think two years now I think
he's his [__] coming up yeah he's a LSU
cat Savage damn how is he like that's
just something he's just a freak he's
just a freak that's the NFL man so
everybody in the NFL everybody like like
free he was in on everything freak
amongst freaks yeah he's his thing's
speed yeah he's so [__] fast to be
that he all to me he's like a second
generation Lawrence Taylor you you knew
you were gonna go far in football when
you like High School yeah I knew when I
when I was in Pop Warner yeah he's just
different just different I always had
belief in myself and then just worked
the hardest and then I would see the
older kids and I would I was able to
compete with the older kids and I just
had that self belief you know you know
what
you know what huh
hold on for a sec
you look like you're getting in shape
I'm always in shape no hold on I'm not
done
you look you lost some weight how much
I don't know hey I don't need you
playing dumb how much weight have you
lost because you know 15. because you're
looking I noticed you're looking a
little bit it might be the girl shirt no
it's not so you know where I'm going
with this I have a question I'm on keto
no that's not the question what
you training a little bit huh no now
hold on training for what well that's
what we're gonna get to and I'm glad
country Wayne's here to experience this
see
I'm I have it on good authority that
Brennan might have been offered some
money dude to fight you understand real
money now I'm talking about the kind of
real money makes you go hey I'm 40 but I
don't mind fighting anybody for that
check you understand
and the kind of money that I would get
in the ring for against the heavyweight
multiple seven figures let me paint the
picture here's the caveat I used to find
the UFC the offer I got was to fight
bare knuckle MMA no gloves the head
Stomps no just yeah but some World Star
Hip-Hop [__] I know what we got
are you training nah man I'm I'm gonna
go show my son's baseball team so my
wife's phone all the time why are you
looking like this I do work on my truck
no you're [__] lying to me why are
you training I'm gonna fight oh
he'd be the first to know you're sneaky
Jorge Mazda offers Brennan shop memories
after shocking 291 knockout win yeah I'm
not fighting Derek Lewis
check is big enough it seems look at my
face there they use the perfect picture
yeah that's true but you've seen like
one one guy knocked a dude out
unconscious he's doing a throat slash
I'm on the mic you seem to be in
fighting shape and that's just life dude
you're holding this truck life
I promise this son of a [__] I think he
might be training secretly no I'm not I
promise yeah you see I'm thinking he's
one of the ones you like to get good in
private
I think he might be taking this offer
seriously do you be the first to know my
man I'd announce it on here
uh-huh yeah I'm just working on my truck
losing weight man I'm under the truck
losing weight see this bull chin we got
current events what we got oh man
deflection deflection by the way if you
guys like stand up I'll be at the
Genesee Theater this Sunday and week
Daddy's doing a theater on a Sunday
Waukegan Illinois near Chicago and I'm
in Spokane this Thursday Friday Saturday
Spokane Washington and then me and Brian
are in skank Fest Las Vegas next week
Friday Saturday live finding the kids
and stand for me and Brian in Iowa in
October Niagara Falls that's almost sold
out Niagara Falls Casino and then
Chicago where you can he's that big boy
but Spokane you're up you got any dates
coming up oh I'm at um I'm in Orlando
um improv this weekend oh nice I like
that I like that club yeah yeah yeah
country Wayne all right our website's
legit usually when Tom would come on
their website's [__] yeah I'm fine
yeah I just got it I think oh that's how
it works it's a little confusing that
outfit was spicy special that outfit was
sick [__] around appreciate it man
hell yeah yeah the spicy though you got
it man for a special that's a good
outfit all right you can give some
current events uh quick question for
Country Wayne though so I see your
YouTube channel and it I literally see
like posts every like hour or a few
minutes so you have a team doing that
out oh yeah possible yeah I got a team I
got a team posting wide yeah they post
all day we got like oh my God I shoot
her like a month worth of videos
um you know but I can film like 20
videos in one day and they're like
they're somewhere like comedy but some
are like like real scary yeah it's crazy
it's a storyline it's like a soap opera
I got my storyline I got another
producer he got his stuff and we share
the characters and yeah and people love
it yeah yeah that's awesome dude
yes sir crushing it definitely crushing
it all right so this is uh I guess this
very the video went viral in 2020 and
it's about a Belgium cycler like ning
some five-year-old girl on the trail why
uh I'll just play the video for you
first and then you get you guys can
judge it on your own
so the dad's filming right now that's
the mother and the kid and you see this
cycle coming in
you see him here oh yeah
I'd beat the [__] yeah so the dad got
pissed off
and he stopped him and he push him down
no I don't know if you got it I mean
that may yeah but the crazy thing about
this so the dad put this out on on you
know on on social media and then the
cyclists actually sued the dad for
defamation and he won the lawsuit wow
for like five something something small
like five or four still he kicks over a
little kid yeah and the dad posted and
then he sues him for death so the
cyclist said that he was he was going to
lose balance and he had to put the knee
out otherwise he would have fell down
hell no but he won the lawsuit but he
shouldn't have stopped he should have
stopped but also just crash in the snow
you Giant
well the thing is you have to stop when
you do that
no I don't have to keep going
he's neither he was saying watch out
watch out and so when you do turn like
this yeah
it would also crash in the snow I didn't
like that girl's attitude the little
girl's attitude spoiled and I feel like
I don't like how the deaths went hey hey
there would there'd be no words I feel
like the girls see the psychics girl was
like this is my road and I'm not and I
think that's how you learn sometimes and
it's uh oh my God no I
um all right so we talked about this on
the last episode but Lauren bobert who's
a congresswoman for Colorado uh so she
you remember we saw the video footage
she got kicked out of the Beetlejuice
music hold on you know why she got
kicked out do you know this
she's vaping she's a like a political
lady she's a democrat in Colorado
Republican that's right she's hardcore
Republic she's part of the freedom
caucus so she goes to the Beetlejuice to
play first date you know she has some
Heavies she's you know she's big titties
and so he he's all up on her titties
dude if you watch the video she's
stroking that thing in the middle of the
theater first date she's vaping she
rubbing that right now she's she's I
find her attractive she's super
attractive vaping she's just been I
guess she got divorced and now she this
she's on the prowl she's on the Proud
this is the guys just met people I can't
believe she's doing that stuff on the
first date nobody thinks it's kind of
hot well listen I I do personally I was
like oh she said I'll vote for him she's
a feisty I don't know her policy the
problem is this here's the problem with
Lauren bobert she said she wasn't vaping
yeah so she said she for she didn't
realize she did but then video footage
came out afterwards that she was
definitely vaping and there was a
pregnant behind her faster to stop she
didn't so they kicked her out oh so it's
The Vaping wasn't that she was jacking
them off in his cat no so there's
groping there was also vaping and
there's also there being loud and she
broke up with the dude now that's what
she says but that's more like a
political she they found out that he's
like a Democrat and he owns like a bar
that that has like uh
she's cute though if you see her there's
some pictures where she's she's hey oh
she's definitely cute yeah she started
out by saying I carry guns and all that
[__] yeah she's a hot chick with a gun
yeah
she only like she only won by 500 votes
and now that she lied about vaping she's
like I don't know what I was thinking no
she said she didn't realize she did yeah
so many more votes now no she probably
that's mine hello what is she running
for again no she's she's a congressman
Congressman yeah yeah okay okay you
don't think you get more votes for
jacking that dude in his khakis at a
play I mean I don't know if she people
are wild nowadays you lose both stuff
like that I think you can either I think
you get bigger we're talking about I
don't know if she was she's from she's
in my hometown yeah it's like people
want people more relatable and real hell
yeah you jack the dude off and Beetle
people doing stuff now anyways like be
honest about it so we won't be a
surprise yeah yeah but she didn't like
it could have been worse it could have
been a lot worse a lot worse could have
been a lot worse it's fine listen
sometimes we all kind of let loose you
know somebody said not enough somebody
says I'm not a Beetlejuice somebody said
somebody said we live in a society and
Beetlejuice you can't be jacking people
off
I'm a straight man but if I go oh my God
okay I don't know man
um how sad does Drake look there all
right so so okay I guess he looks at
Drake has a new song out called slime
you out and then apparently Halle Berry
is saying that uh he asked her to use if
she could he could use her image she
said no she said no he still did it
still used it and the Slime yeah I don't
know it I'm guessing it means like you
know coming on her
coming on someone's face imagine you're
disgusting that is what it means though
it has to be slime you out I don't know
I would imagine countries younger than
all is that yeah do the kids say slime
you out I I really ain't never heard of
that term but it looks like that who who
attacks a girl trying to slime you out
like that looks like gonorrhea yeah or
an alien got excited yeah yeah but also
here here's where I'm at on it I think
it's all just publicity for his album I
I don't I think he told Hallie hey
that's what I'm gonna do nobody
disrespects Halle Berry
to do I was Fu to me not cool you get it
yeah she's replying to comments
because someone said it was like a
public it's good marketing for Drake I'm
almost no matter what I'm a huge the
photo is owned by a Getty Images yeah
but I mean she but if Drake really did
ask her can I use it she said no and he
still used it that's kind of messed up
if that's real I don't know how do those
companies end up owning your image like
that yeah I don't know that either the
Getty Images and they can sue you like
if you use the picture and don't pay for
it from them even though it's you they
how do they do that like once you post
something online so so a photographer
photographer takes a picture paparazzi
that's his picture even though it's your
image like he that's his picture so you
can't use his art for your promo how f
up is it but it's my face bro I know but
but the thing is like so it'd be exactly
like say somebody get takes a bunch of
professional pictures of you right in a
in a studio now they treat those
pictures so what they do is they'll take
those pictures and they edit them and
they do the stuff that they do that's
work they've put into that so that's his
property
it's your image but it's his property if
you use it if you use that picture to
make money okay that that is then so if
you use this promotion to sell tickets
that's their problem and that you can
get how [__] up is that though
um it's I don't know right like it's
because the paparazzi let's say Leonardo
DiCaprio jumps out at Malibu they snap
these pictures they sell to TMZ Leo
doesn't get a cut of that but if Leo
uses it's a good law actually because
otherwise you would never have you would
never have imagery you've got to make
images
profitable in a way yeah but the artist
should be able to use whatever they want
it's their likeness I know the problem
with that is that when you shoot a movie
or a TV show you could say the same
thing you get paid man you get slimed
out yeah I don't know you're right it's
a weird it's a weird gray area there's
something about if you're in public it's
like you're supposed to be
I know she's I love her because she's
she's our best audience I'm doing it
just for her I love her you're our best
audience
you already know that it's you there's a
potential of you being you know taking a
picture of in public if you're not like
a younger kid or whatever like that so
you're assuming that responsible like
but you know that you can get a picture
taken of you so that's something I I
kind of understand it though it's just
weird that only one person can make
money off of it and if you yeah like
there should be some sort of agreement
well there is you can buy the image
that's [__] up so you got to call and
get you yeah
it's always for sale
um so this I'm not familiar with this
NBA player but I'm sure you guys know
this yeah
so he mentioned something like if he had
a year of training he could be Jon Jones
in MMA he's out of his [__] mind yeah
so I'll just play this clip for you real
quick yeah I lit him up on Twitter did
you yep
but like I said with a year of the
training defense I just need ground
defense apparently he's a black belt in
karate athletes it's like okay JJ can
move how you move that guy's hairline's
horrible
we're okay
he started learning how to use your
hands and your feet what after college
oh bodies oh buddy six years old so like
the same thing for me though is the
opposite for him because he's been
wrestling for that long let me know his
wrestling moves and things like that
he's in foreign
that's no joke but it's a different
thing Jon Jones would mop the floor I
hope it's not a fight that's coming up
no John would you know it's never
happening no yeah all their fights are
with their hair
it's a horrible take I've been I've been
punching you know in the backyard since
I was six okay okay
people man internet became addictive I
think some people just want to talk now
I agree and it's it's clicks it's
traction he knows damn well it's a new
drug man yeah but also but what's but
the reason they do it is if you look at
the comments people like yeah man you're
six eight John's only six four I bet you
could whoop his ass so they give him
this they hype that's not what I think
about I think about the fact that he's
clearly a very special athlete right I
mean you played in the NBA but it
doesn't translate to fighting it's not
yeah he might be a black belt in martial
arts or something I think he's like 2-0
in kickbox something like that I'm like
correct so he blocked on Karate is there
anything is there any video of him
moving around
I don't know it doesn't yeah but there's
no way he's winning that fight yeah no
he's not beating I just need to learn
the ground stuff just give me a year oh
yeah I know you're stupid because you
think in a year you could defend a
takedown from Jon Jones yeah you get why
because he took down DC two times
but you'll figure out in a year dumbass
yeah dumbass I mean he has no idea he's
never fought anybody ignorance is bliss
ignorance is bliss God bless them
oh no no
no no one personally I wouldn't take
this level
[Applause]
you did that WWE [__] wait wait wait
look at this yeah
for a little bit I said bro needs to be
in WrestleMania
yeah
faith in your Landing boom yeah
that's my orange back
the technique was crazy how did they not
call penalty
yeah they threw a flag did they they
should I don't know that's hilarious to
me
um all right uh this is the European
fella describing the taste of the his
pepper spray we're talking about getting
pepper sprayed before on earlier shows
if have you ever been Peppers oh yeah in
the military oh damn you have to do it
right yeah I went to basic training oh I
ain't go bet AIT I ain't gonna wait
while I just went b-wall I ain't go back
b-wall
why'd open his mouth like that
he said that tastes like Jack Daniels
yeah
JD hey man have anybody ever sprayed
somebody that close God that's so close
yeah that's so damn also hey is that guy
criminal or is is this is this down for
love I think he's just drunk and
disorderly I
started oh my God no man no hold up man
hold up man hold up man did they just
man first of all he scored this in this
man in his mouth
eyeballs and mouth
what's going on
we don't know
I've never seen someone that close
it tastes like JD that tastes like look
at his teeth I know it's pretty messy
man what where is this like never mind
man oh somewhere in England maybe I
don't know oh yeah
yeah his teeth were tough that pepper
spray must be vegan man
how do you take that I I think high or
drunk that he doesn't even know what's
going on man who knows
this is so funny this thing oh yeah
okay so uh this will be the last one
then let me find another one hold on
people are crazy which one's the best
one you think
oh look they're all pretty good let's
just do this one
last one
full racer 80 years old oh damn he
tripped him yeah
[Music]
hey man they moved pretty good if I hate
it yeah
well there you go all right that's a
grandpa tripped her and turned turning
on the Jets at that age murder attempt
yep that's funny is that a chance
it's some of the most fun I had I really
appreciate you guys dude I've been a fan
for a while I know you're a work ethic
man so I respect the [__] out of it
you're more tutorial new specials on
Netflix right now you're gonna watch it
a woman's prayer a woman's prayer yeah
that's your mother's prayer that's what
it is not yeah yes my mom's prayers you
know I became the man she wanted me to
be wow dude that's a great title a
woman's prayer it's on Netflix right now
then he's in Orlando this weekend
cooking up in the kitchen cooking up new
material cooking up man then you're in
Manchester Connecticut Lexington I love
Lexington Dayton Ohio
Naples You misspelled Naples you're
doing all you're doing the same the same
circuit we do yeah great
it's great man it's it's it's it's a
real cool it's amazing the comments made
me meet other Comics you kind of it's a
fraternity it's a fraternity yeah you
know the grind yeah it's like everybody
but we're a special kind of Misfit too
you know what I mean it's like it's a
language it's an intimacy it's it's a
language and you know what that's one
thing everybody respect comes when they
know you get on that stage everybody and
every other art know it's the hardest
art in the world 100 it's like we walk
around with yeah we're like the wmba of
entertainment yeah nobody watched it it
never gets easy Spokane see this
man that's amazing